[Musique]
on est en charge de la protection de ce
bâtiment contre la menace sous marine
tellement dégoûté
ok là je viens d'atterrir sur la frégate
auvergne un immense bateau militaire de
l'armée française je me trouve
exactement ici en pleine mer
méditerranée entre la corse et toulon
l'objectif passé 24 heures à bord où je
vais suivre les marins dans leur mission
qui est ultra confidentielle la chasse
d'un sous marin nucléaire
alors évidemment landais pas en pleine
guerre mondiale donc ce sous-marin et
les français
mais tout ça se fait dans les conditions
du réel
j'espère donc que vous êtes prêt parce
que là ça risque de tanguer
[Musique]
un bâtiment de guerre c'est pas
forcément facile de s'y repérer donc les
plans sont là bas on et 250 sur les
frégates anti-sous-marines dans cette
génération
aujourd'hui on a 150 marins un
désarmement important de la fremm ce
sont des missiles on a des missiles
antiaériens et puis des missiles de
croisière naval verrez un peu partout
aussi qui en systèmes de communication
donc ça parle de ce qu'on appelle un
adulte et deux dans une zone dédiée à la
décontamination
lorsqu'il ya une attaque chimique
bactériologique ou même nucléaire sur le
bâtiment dans ces cas là on est capable
de complètement fermée tout contact avec
l'extérieur c'est ce qu'on appelle passé
en citadelle donc je savais arrière
cette porte
il ya donc le central opérations c'est
ici que la marine en train de faire son
exercice à essayer de détecter tout
simplement le sous marin est donc ils
sont en plein exercice
en ce moment on va voir comment ça se
déroule ouvrir la porte
enfin on va dire défection
[Musique]
alors actuellement se trouve dans le
centre à l'opération de la frégate
auvergne donc la partie où va se gérer
toutes les opérations la conduite des
opérations l'exercice cette semaine il
est à dominante anti sous marine on
donne une position de départ ont fait un
port fictif en fait dans l'océan qu'on
définit on la unités précieuses fait un
bâtiment de la marine actuellement la la
scène qui joue avec nous et on l'a fait
partir d'un point et on doit lui faire
rallier un point en sécurité et nous on
est en charge de la protection de ce
bâtiment contre la menace sous marine
une démission un des objectifs c'est de
détecter le marin nucléaire une des
façons de le faire ça va être de voir
sous la mer mais d'avoir aussi des
activités et des repérages qui vont se
faire au niveau de la mer et dans les
airs avec notamment l'hélicoptère donc
là on est au coeur de cette mission
c'est ici que ça se passe
on a deux saunas on a le sonar à l'avant
fitch à la coque et on a un sonar
remorqué
un fait qu'on peut l'imaginer dans l'eau
un sonar c'est quoi c'est quelque chose
qui va émettre une onde depuis le bateau
et si cette onde nous revient d'une
certaine façon c'est qu'il ya un
obstacle sur notre chemin
alors à partir de là tout le travail des
opérateurs qui sont présents ici c'est
être d'analyser cette onde qui nous est
retourné pour essayer de comprendre ce
que c'est ce que c'est un mammifère est
ce que c'est un bateau est ce que c'est
un sous-marin éventuellement on l'espère
et donc c'est les éléments qu'on doit
déterminer ici du coup là on va voir
tout de suite la mise à l'eau des engins
notamment d'un sonar qui va permettre
donc d'arriver à détecter éventuellement
le sous marin nucléaire
[Musique]
on a un autre moyen d'action c'est
l'hélicoptère qu'on abhorre le nh90 qui
peut être un moyen aussi de réagir parce
que c'est un moyen qu'on peut envoyer
sur la menace
l'hélicoptère qu'on voyait très
impressionnant on va pas se mentir c'est
le caïman marine et c'est avec cet
hélicoptère qu'on va essayer de repérer
le sous marin tout à l'heure je sais de
paca c'est quoi que ce soit ça ouais
mais là c'est bien pour ça donc on est
dans le cockpit était à la place du
pilote moi à la place du tacot donc le
tacot il a un deux rôles c'est le chef
de mission
il va récupérer les informations que lui
donne son opérateur censeurs derrière à
partir de là il va communiquer avec le
bateau parce qu'on travaille jamais
seule on travaille toujours en coupe
pour proposer une idée de manoeuvre et
après il va demander à son pilote de fer
lit des manoeuvres écoute pilote je veux
que tu ailles à tel endroit qu'on fasse
il confessa est le pilote qui est
l'expert aéronautique va dire oui c'est
faisable ou non parce que on risque de
se mettre en danger pour telle ou telle
raison en fait on s'assistent en
permanence et c'est un dialogue en
permanence dans le cockpit et c'est
absolument nécessaire pour réussir la
mission
[Musique]
mais en route la machine on fait tous
les essais sonar radars etc
quand tout est bon on décolle et on ira
vérifier que le sous-marin est pas dans
une zone où l'unité précieuse va se
rendre un peu plus tard et si jamais on
trouve le sous marin on se mettra à
travailler ensemble pour essayer d'avoir
un maximum d'informations et de conduire
une attaque écoulée le sous marin avant
qu'ils écoulaient l'unité précieuse bon
alors pendant que je me change je vous
expliquer vitesse qu'on va faire à bord
en gros pour repérer ce sous marin
nucléaire l'hélicoptère va utiliser deux
choses la première chose c'est le sonar
lui est lâché dans l'eau il fonctionne
comme celui du bateau pour faire
vraiment très simple par contre quand le
sonar est lâché et bien l'hélico ne peut
pas bouger
et la deuxième chose qu'on va pouvoir
utiliser pour repérer le sous marin
nucléaire c'est les bouées et les bouées
c'est pas celle que vous utilisez dans
votre piscine
en fait ça ressemble à ça elles sont un
peu moins performante que le sonar les
en revanche lorsqu'elles sont lâchés eh
bien ils ne sont pas récupérés et donc
ce que ça veut dire c'est que les nico
peut continuer à bouger et lâcher comme
ça donc des bouées dans l'eau en
avançant
[Musique]
j'ai pensé par les six les pasteurs tu
peux exploiter les deux il ya l'avion
qui arrivait devant donc le petit rush
de coordination entre d'autres
voilà ma montre comment on allait trop
sec 2o que l'avion 80e avec et beau
écrire donc là on va essayer de
travailler en coopération
le bateau et l'atlantique nord pour
enfermer le contact le berceau
l'attraper
[Musique]
franchement c'est l'affluence
ok
[Musique]
tu crois quoi ce truc là oui c'est vrai
mais les sens
il vous dira de 80 ombre d un doute dans
les bouges je le fais quand même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on n'a pas réussi à localiser le
sous-marin malheureusement la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'on en fait sécuriser
une zone pour permettre à limiter
précieuse de progresser sans être
attaqué par le sma donc ça reste quand
même une victoire de ce point de vue là
on joue jamais gagnants et perdants dans
l'exercice même si le sous marin père ou
même si on perd pour nous on progresse
pratiquement pas ce qu'on dit ballon
s'est fait avoir sur sept succès
dominante
j'adapterai ma tactique était encore
encore plus robuste finalement perdre
dans l'exercice c'est toujours un
meilleur moyen de progresser dans le
cadre de la conduite des opérations par
la suite déjà un surnom c'est les deux
chiens jaunes
quel est votre rôle est alors tout à
fait je suis à jaune parce qu'en fait
comme ça reste dans une vie assez
bruyant la peau noire a envoyé on crie
sur les jambes pour le comprendre et les
jaunes pas du fait que roi dagobert
draguignan je parle on organise la
sécurité
non
après ce nom
[Musique]
du coup les ce qui se passe en ce moment
a envoyé un autre bateau en face c'est
une phase de ravitaillement faire
vraiment très simple pour aller chercher
du gasoil ces deux bateaux qui vont se
laisser parallèle très proche et avancer
ensemble à la même vitesse
ensuite passer des tuyaux entre les deux
et puis transférée du gazole entre le
bâtiment ravitailleurs et le g
c'est un bateau c'est sept jours sur
sept 24 heures sur 24 pendant des jours
des semaines parfois des mois pour voir
dur à la mer il et a besoin de se
ravitailler 30 ans sera évitée et en
gazole en carburant en vivre aussi en
eau éventuellement et donc c'est ce
qu'on est en train de faire en ce moment
avec la marne qui est derrière moi un
équipage c'est un peu comme un petit
village à une sorte de communauté les
gens qui vivent ensemble
on y trouve toutes sortes de métiers
toutes sortes de spécialités
ça va du boulanger aux spécialistes de
réflexion qui sous marine en passant par
l'électricien et quand on vous dit que
un bateau comme ça c'est vraiment un
village sur la mer il ya même une sorte
de petit supermarché une coopérative ici
on peut acheter toutes sortes de choses
comme un petit magasin pour les marins
donc ce qu'on appelle les produits de
représentation donc les t-shirts de
sport le magnifique baignoire verne et
c'est ce qui est intéressant c'est que
l'argent généré par les bénéfices de la
coopérative en fait sert à financer des
activités de cohésion pour les mains
c'est avec ses bénéfices là qu'on va se
payer un repas tous ensemble en escale
par exemple et là tandis que benjamin a
obligé de prendre une serviette
on va du coup acheter une serviette en
juin super merci beaucoup
[Musique]
alors vous le voyez le color en ce
moment c'est une lumière assez est
admise est assez particulière pourquoi
et bien parce que le soir donc aux
alentours de 20h jusqu'au lendemain
matin la lumière elle est un site
simplement pour garder un rythme au sein
du bateau c'est à dire que les gens qui
bossent ici la nuit en a qui voient
quasiment jamais le jour donc c'est
important d'avoir une alternance entre
les lumières plus tamisée le soir et des
lumières un peu plus forte la journée
[Musique]
m
alors il est tout juste 6h40 dans une
vingtaine de minutes c'est le branle-bas
autrement dit le réveil général pour
tout le monde avec une musique un
discours qu'il a prononcé la personne en
charge ce matin a proposé de venir pour
faire un petit discours
on ira salut c'est hugo du média hugo
décrypte bonne matinée à tous et
réveillez vous tranquillement en
tranquillement il ya eu pas trop
tranquillement ce qui est quand même des
choses à faire
aujourd'hui on est parti de mon côté
pour nouveau résumé de l'actualité du
jour
spéciale dédicace à tous ceux qui
suivent notre chaîne youtube et que j'ai
pu croiser hier merci à vous du boucher
mais vous regardez en ce moment ce
reportage mettez un petit bleu est
évidemment abonnez vous et évidemment et
dans les commentaires n'hésitez pas à
dire bonjour à tout l'équipage qui est
présent à issy les moulineaux
quand ils seront de retour sur la terre
ferme où la prenez soin de vous
présenter aux touristes et on se dit
acolytes
[Musique]